don't [ __ ] on duncan duncan's fire
dunkin donuts is the best coffee in
america dude thank you you know who else
drinks duncan huh
isis and you guys aren't american if
you're drinking [ __ ] duncan that's on
record so it's an american company
where's it
dude i i think it's based out of the
east coast
it's based out of [ __ ] in the middle
east it's better than it's let's go to
sheboygan dunk sheboygan dunkin donuts
closes down
let me show you coffee let me show you
freaking tit homos what's going on first
duncan was opened in
here we go right here where at mass
massachusetts quincy
is the subway is closed following an
arson over the weekend police say a
teenager
is responsible for all that damage
newswatch 16's nikki krause joins us
live from the central pennsylvania
newsroom with more tonight nikki
i think he looks sad as [ __ ] julie a lot
of people in shimokin are upset that
dunkin donuts is closed because they
didn't have anywhere else to go for
coffee and donuts
today we also learned new information
about the teenage girl police
charged with setting the place on fire
yellow tape surrounds the dunkin donuts
on west sunbury street in shimokin
the popular donut shop is closed until
further notice
because of extensive fire damage there's
a lot of people that's definitely going
to miss it no doubt about
it a teenager is charged with starting a
fire inside the restaurant on saturday
night
shimokin police officer ray psycho says
no one was hurt psycho
your freaking police officer named ray
psycho bro raikko probably turns that
body cam off if you catch me
yeah dude ray take a [ __ ] few people
oh yeah right turn that camera oh my bad
i forgot to turn that [ __ ] on
yeah yeah he's the only police officer
that has a couple of teardrop
tattoos off his left cobweb on his elbow
let's go officer psycho and this one you
get for why are you staying open on
saturday night you're a donut shop
you're selling donuts apparently it's
all they have in that city though
psycho says the fire was started inside
the women's
bathroom the toilet paper dispenser was
lit on fire and within about a minute
the entire place was filled up with
smoke
the mother did explain that she's
recently been put on new medication
right now the 13-year-old who admitted
to setting the fire it's currently
at the detention center
now i have to rely on myself to go to
maybe a turkey hill or something where i
don't like their donuts i'd rather the
donuts at dunkin donuts
and i'm kind of dealing with it but i
really miss dunkin donuts okay i go
there you don't need anything
you can make a croissant or i get some
coffee powerade if i'm dehydrated i sit
there all the time
if i have any like legal work that i
need to do
don't miss that place hold on
legal go back to my boy dutch
smith bro and let's see where he's going
how fake of a name is that what's your
name dutch schmidt
i get a chicken bacon christmassy on the
right car dunks back from the top bro
let's take dutch off top
dog and this is long neck before
something happened to him
before he got electrocuted or whatever
it's stretched out and how many times
that lady say don it's gonna you need a
turkey hill donuts we're gonna miss the
donuts
i'm gonna go to turkey hill donna
i really miss dunkin donuts i go to
every day i get a chicken bacon
croissant or i get some coffee
powerade if i'm dehydrated i'll sit
there all the time
if i have any like legal work that i
need to do i go there i meet with my
attorneys there
i'm gonna miss that place when if it
don't open up
yeah a lot of my friends go in there get
the cold coffee
well iced coffee i guess it's called
people miss their local
hangouts what is going on hey what city
is this what
city's filled with these mutants because
i ain't going to their dunk donuts hey
we got to get dutch smith on the line
there's not a chance that's his real
name smith
dutch is on the [ __ ] run y'all figure
it out
he ain't calling it our [ __ ] show
look and here's i'm going to go this on
the
on his uh profile picture i'm gonna say
at this point
it's kind of a thick chick with two kids
it's gonna be his profile picture
i'm just throwing that out there he's a
while there he is doug smith what's up
not him dog
lives in shamokin boom his real name
might be
dutch okay afterwards very strange oh
he's a white rapper
oh let's hear some of his tracks son
maybe rapt about this dunkin donuts
dunkin donuts in the corn coffee what
are they calling iced
cool coffee iced coffee oh here he is
truck it's called trust him
who is he a christian rapper we'll see
and hit it
he larps live-action role-play
ice coffee dutch my beautiful blossom
my shrouded wolf my dark princess that's
edna from dunkin donuts did you get the
book
the production i did everything you
asked me to i made him fall in love with
me
but he always has the book and he keeps
talking about this jesus did you dare
say that name
well i don't know what else you want me
to do
here take this oh
make him eat
get the book and i will set you free no
what happened
no i gotta deal with this every day i
lose sleep
every day yes hit him tell him dutch
that's him right
[Music]
[Music]
oh damn he's
[Music]
dutch is getting wild i know i love this
suit he has on
very medieval well well dutch is doing
it man that's what he's doing
yeah body armor of god he's a christian
rapper i don't know if he's coming on
this show
well i'm just amazed you could see he
turned his life around from that moment
when you know somebody that's the
burning bush everybody has that burning
bush in their life
that started a fire under his ass the
brothers not being there anymore for
legal fees would you say there i said
the burning duncan
instead of the burning bush yeah yep